ces gens là
proche par rapport au message sujet des
ses soins messagerie
comme quoi je me plaignais les
conditions de travail du salaire
et voilà 2021
je m'entretiens préalable les deux
semaines après c'était fini chez amazon
j'ai compris que ça que ça fonctionnait
comme ça que si on parle trop ils font
en sorte
comprennent apporte
même ceux qui sont plus haut les
managers
autre ils n'ont pas trop le droit de
s'exprimer
de la duration moment on soutient notre
camarade jérémy paglia long qui a fait
l'objet d'un licenciement sac de la part
d'amazon en 2021 alors qu'ils étaient
par ailleurs le salarié de l'année 2020
et qui était plutôt reconnu pour ses
qualités professionnelles
aujourd'hui on dénonce les pratiques en
cours au sein d'amazon et notamment leur
enregistrement à son insu de notre
représentant de section syndicale qui a
été enregistré lors de ses déclarations
dans le cadre de son mandat syndical où
il alerté les salariés sur les pratiques
d'amazon qui consiste notamment à
demander aux salariés à remplir les
attestations contre d'autres seriez en
vue de faciliter leur licenciement basse
et d'intimidation et c'est les moyens de
pression donc des cases et d'amazon un
salarié aux critiques et les conditions
de travail soient ils se retrouvent
licenciés comme monsieur paglia ou soit
s'ils bénéficient d'une protection
relative comme notre représentant de
section syndicale il fait l'objet
d'intimidations et ça c'est des
pratiques on peut pas laisser passer
on attend dire ça prend